d'accord mais je regarde à la giscard la
france au fond des yeux d'accord au
revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça sera pas tard si un candidat sort de
façon carrée net et qu' il apporte un
projet puissant qu'il prend l'espace
médiatique
[Musique]
j'ai rappelé le 4 décembre
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez du second tour le soir du
premier tour
[Musique]
on ne me choque pas
maintenant ma part je suis pas pour le
retour la peine de mort parce que je
serai du mal être le bourreau donc j'ai
dû j'aurais du mal à faire faire à un
autre je ne peux pas faire moins
d'erreurs judiciaires de toujours
arriver en revanche on va faire la
vierge effarouchée lorsqu'on voit un
sondage qui dit qu'on est pour la peine
de mort en poserait pas ces questions si
on avait un système judiciaire
performant si des sanctions étaient
réellement appliquées contre ceux qui
nuisent sans arrêt et si on avait un
système de vraie perpétuité pour les
plus grands criminels les plus dangereux
ceux qui portent atteinte à la société
et aux inquiétudes
[Musique]
je ne cherche pas de ministère
non
pas pour le maire certains films font
plus et politique que le maire pendant
le festival de cannes
[Musique]
aux prochains
jeux j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs les
meilleurs souvenirs c'était quand j'ai
quand je connaissais personne que
j'étais un gamin un adolescent à cannes
et que j'arrivais à rentrer par
effraction
il est moins bon que celui que j'avais
quand je faisais 23 heures
parce que j'en ai fait plus quelques
envois de trois heures et ça se dégrade
avec l'âge je court plusieurs fois par
semaine